to me they're more powerful computers
that will continue to replace your tasks
and this thing with it the chat bot and
the writing It's ability to write let it
write things that nobody wanted to write
like instruction manuals or let it let
it write an instruction manual nobody
wants to write those things or tour
guides okay that all the things that
were never signed by authors let the
thing write those and sure yes and it'll
put some people out of work so what
happens now is when you go to college or
you get educated at all you don't want
to learn a trade because that could go
extinct you know you don't want to learn
how to make horse-drawn buggies because
that could go extinct what you want to
do is learn how to think
how to put together new information into
new ideas so that you can always be out
ahead and be have value to an employer
and so
that's that's so education is going to
have to respond to this they don't tell
you this but a computer flies your
Airplane the pilots in there basically
for show
the computer flies the airplane
especially the old ones know but the
modern ones it's flown by a computer
basically on all every practically all
elements of it okay are you saying oh
it's taking away my Humanity no it's
making the plane safer don't you want
that okay so by the way if the movie
airport that one of the early disaster
movies I think was 1970. I I recently
saw that and I said oh my gosh you took
a look inside the cockpit there were
four people in the cockpit there's a
pilot the co-pilot the Navigator the
this it's like oh my gosh it's so so yes
times have changed a computer beat us a
chess a com and that was long ago a
computer beat the best chess player a
computer beat it's a Jeopardy talk about
the human culture losing to a computer
so the the world didn't come to an end
when that happened that is people didn't
react emotionally uh when that happened
but all of a sudden you say write me an
essay on the Etruscans and out comes an
essay that's basically perfect and
people freak out because now it's in
your backyard when we've always had it
in our backyard holding aside the fear
that is in every single
a computer takes over the world movie
you know like Terminator or the Matrix
holding those aside for the moment I
think a more immediate let's call it a
threat
is
the capacity of computers to fake things
to fake your voice your face create a
three-dimensional version of you based
on just a few photographs all right
we've already had this happen from what
I've read where they sample of the voice
of a loved one of yours and then that
loved one calls you it's all fake now
calls you and say I'm I'm touring
Istanbul and I lost my credit card can I
use your credit card while I'm here and
I'll pay you back when I get them and
you recognize the voice you recognize
everything about it it might have even
been a video call then you give them
your credit card and bought a bing uh AI
just stole your credit card suppose you
there are two countries that are already
not getting along all right and then you
fake an announcement of the leader of
one of those countries that they're
going to invade this afternoon and the
other country then reacts to this and
then it completes complete deadly chaos
even though neither leader said what the
Deep fake claimed it did so we already
have the problem of misinformation
disinformation uh people believing
they're experts because they spend a few
times a few minutes reading a Google
page and then they override the actual
opinion of an actual expert and so
that's already created havoc
uh it's in the social media circles so
so this would magnify that now there's a
part of me the chess game playing part
of me where you have to set up pieces
and then you look for an end game the
part of me wonders
maybe AI
will create such good fakes
that no one will trust the internet
anymore for anything and we just have to
Simply shut it down
that would be interesting because it's
already we've already seen the debt it's
done some great things okay but we've
already seen the damage that it has
caused the tribalization of of of
culture and civilization and their
hatred the Cesspool that festers in you
know we've seen it I've seen it you've
surely seen it I've been in it so maybe
it's the final nail of a coffin in the
internet 30 years it was a good run from
the early 90s to the early 20s and 2020s
now it's time for the next thing that
could be the greatest gift of AI to the
internet that it shuts down the internet
that we that the internet the internet
gets a vote of no confidence from us